don't let him grab you
rejection
so
[Music]
it's important in this drill
that you're not just rolling him
his center
must traverse
move it up
and it must move
we don't know
let's move it across the map yep yep
okay so not
here
oh
not
here
[Music]
oh
same thing don't let him touch
won't pop
oh he doesn't touch
see contact boom
you can start moving now
don't hesitate to strike or you'll get
there
okay
i'm not letting him
get his friend
you're getting his grip i i have the ikg
so it's hurting
in this last one
oh this is wrong
this i already have his
body
don't let him get you don't let him get
you then he's got you
okay you're all ready
as he's reaching
wall
[Music]
he's reaching
reach
connection here
then seek connection just up let him
touch you
then there you have it
connection don't block it
you already have it
boom touch
and yield where it wants to
so
he's that time he's coming in is a lot
of energy right there so i go around it
you see
sometimes like you have a lot of reach
you see i can see on the outside
but contact
[Music]
look at that
okay
a few points
so this adhesion
can go this adhesion can uh did you feel
it get tight
can be
amplified by
how i am doing the coq projection so i
can project at an angle where it's
actually going off
but i can't project at an angle where
tightening up
point
i think you are interdependent so you
can amplify one why what you do with the
other and of course you can
de-amplify one by what you do with the
others you have to keep that in mind and
so this is why you train
i train
once i identify the yin hand
i train to intensify the friction
do you understand i'm feeling it i'm not
looking at what i'm doing with your arm
i'm deciding whether it's getting loose
or getting tighter
and then as i identify the young hand
it's the same thing
i go by the feeling what is the feeling
i feel his center and i feel the ground
vector pressurizing
so if i take this pop around his center
i'll feel it lightening not pressurizing
the pressurized boom is what i'm trying
to do again don't go for a tactic like
you're over here
it's going for friction pressure
friction
pressure
secondly
as they are interdependent in terms of
reaching their full amplification
they also
can
assist the other one by taking away
either friction or pressure okay so for
example do you do the same thing and
let's say you're like going
whoa lots of pressure and it's starting
to cave your stance or your positioning
in space okay
so you can change it so i'll come around
this way
but i feel my base being compromised
with lots of pressure i'll come around
this way
so what i did is felt the pressure
pressure pressure pressure on here
starting to cave my base or my
positioning and so it yields and picks
up the same pressure
on that side
in the same way
what i do between my hands i can do with
my body
so
friction pressure pressure and i could
yield you see in my stance
ready to go
this is always much better to do
than
this
you got you got outperformed the work
requirement was beyond your performance
envelope
or this one
okay
so you combining these things
movement is working
your goals here with friction
and with pressure
nobody should have the face over
challenge
or their
spatial integrity
compromise from being outperformed okay
standing and we already moved and you
can use your movement in the same way as
previously described we will go back to
uh the
but it's the same projection
meaning i don't i'm not rolling him
i'm looking for the projection
the projection
okay
so again
coach you paul
i'm not trying to roll him
i'm not trying to throw him
you you're closer and caught you whole
with that
with no fall
you projected and traversed the center
across the map okay
so when you come here you're not going
like this
[Music]
you're not even accelerating him into
the room
his center
is coming up i want the ground better i
want to challenge
though
got it
i don't care which direction
but it it doesn't roll
it gets picked up
and traverses the map okay try it again
okay so before we go to uh yokata i have
to
stop using my grips and cutting my grip
off
so
even though he has a
grab i don't use the grab i don't use
his fingers
or anything this is basically just just
an adhesion
so i find that same thing
don't stress the grips
project
and here
again it looks like there's a ledge but
i'm not using the ledge
okay i'm not pushing down
it's going out
and this hand is doing the projection so
this is leading
base
[Music]
always going forward
now
put your weight on this hand this hand
goes on the ground
don't cut your hand off